don't let him get away I'm right behind
you Scott
yeah
hero hero traitors gate closed till
morning by barons decree
that's why I'm not a politician stops
the poor going where they should never
need the Commons making a bad situation
hey what do you think
walk down shutting the city up like this
won't stop the gloom spread it
we're only sitting over coffee
glue everywhere
who smothered the play
come on out so I can crack your head
wasn't anything I guess too bad yeah
the cost fairly quiet when use the right
way Aaron made this thing sound noisier
than it is
court closed for the night
no thoroughfare what are you looking at
it's price on that jewel Tomas I can cut
through the jeweler's to get around
these gates
besides that mask sounds interesting
damn lights are still on a blink anyone
left who knows how to fix these frigging
things good luck finding it kills me
whose fingers
doesn't feel safe mistress
no there's someone here
every friggin bells I don't like this
something feels wrong
doesn't feel safe on the streets
drinks at the station come la smell
unless you know what tavern where they
won't spit in the watchman's fine
a few guards residents upstairs stealing
the mask shouldn't be a problem
I hate that friggin bird goes crazy
every time someone makes a noise and if
I had a lady like his upstairs I would
not let the bet go cold
I'm glad when this is all over all these
beauties need a job starving if he's got
this on show what else has he got
to walk the streets these days I wonder
if I should check on his wife I need to
sleep
these jewels are glass still a little
fetch good coin from someone who doesn't
know better I'll see myself out an
upstairs window should get me over that
gate breath habit to walk the streets
soldier still not ready let's see how
cousin I half expected us to join the
pause and when San Luis laughing about
we have town
let us pray that it does not poor
more extravagant than my usual masks one
for the collection never know when I'll
be invited to a ball
I'm not feeling that well
keep yourself together no rocks teeth
this is my way out but once I drop down
there's no coming back
the old man remembers the shellfish
fires flames so bright night became day
Oh Jeremy
distant lightly
if you're kidding I swear oh please
please
to do that here
smokin food with a face that the rapist
would throw back
tired already do everyone a favor
careful she's off the festive piss pot
you're from up esport way right
is the gloom there yet yep river drains
were clogged with the drought